place à votre journal de l'afrique sur
france 24 très heureux de vous retrouver
dans l'actualité du continent africain
aujourd'hui et dépouillement en cours au
kenya ont voté pour des représentants
locaux nationaux et un président
résultats attendus d'ici une semaine les
risques de fraudes sont dans tous les
esprits nous irons à nairobi en guinée
le fn décès n'est plus le front national
pour la défense de la constitution a été
dissous par la junte au pouvoir il
s'opposait au minitère depuis des mois
nous serons à conakry il y avait des
crèmes les pilules il ya désormais les
boissons des breuvages censé faire la
peau claire un business juteux n'est
dangereux exemple au cameroun
plus d'un kenyan sur deux s'est déplacé
pour voter ce mardi était jour de
scrutin local législatif et présidentiel
il s'agit là d'élire le cinquième
président du pays le successeur du
kenyatta le duel s'annonce serré entre
deux anciens alliés raïla odinga et
william ruto et les regards se tournent
aussi vers la commission électorale pas
question de répéter la saga de 2017 un
scrutin invalidées en raison
d'irrégularités
des incidents ont eu lieu lundi
concernant la distribution de matériel
électoral le point à nairobi avec
bastien renault
le décompte des voix va durer une bonne
partie de la nuit ici au kenya les
personnes que vous voyez derrière moi
sont des membres de la commission
électorale et des observateurs des
partis politiques et ils vont passer les
prochaines heures à étudier les
bulletins pour les six différentes
élections auxquelles ont dû participer
les kenyans aujourd'hui à savoir bien
évidemment l'élection présidentielle
mais aussi à l'élection des gouverneurs
des députés des représentantes des
femmes à l'assemblée des sénateurs ou
encore des membres des assemblées des
comtés et selon ces observateurs des
partis politiques est bien l'élection
s'est plutôt bien déroulée je vous
propose de les écouter et surtout s'est
fait dans le calme les agents de la
commission se sont bien comportés le
vote s'est très bien déroulée même si le
taux de participation n'est pas très bon
nous avons dépassé les 51 % de votants
ce bureau c'est un peu au dessus de la
moyenne des cafés à baba fareed
le vote s'est bien déroulé les candidats
des partis à zinio ait eu des as ont
coopéré nous nous sommes bien organisés
et jusqu'à présent nous n'avons vu aucun
problème
outre ces commentaires des observateurs
des partis politiques il faudra faire
attention au cours des prochains jours
aux observateurs internationaux qui peut
être auront une vision différente de
cette élection toujours est il que la
commission électorale a été sous le feu
des critiques des kenyans plusieurs
reprises durant cette élection
l'élection est d'ailleurs été suspendu
dans la région de wajir au nord du pays
puisqu'il ya eu des violences au cours
des derniers jours dans la région de
mombasa les bulletins pour l'élection
des gouverneurs et bien à comporter des
erreurs elle a aussi été repoussés dans
ce comté dans plusieurs autres comtés du
pays et puis il ya eu aussi des
problèmes avec les tablettes biométrique
qui permettent d'enregistrer les
électeurs de vérifier leur identité
certaines ne fonctionnait pas retards
dans l'ouverture des bureaux de vote la
commission électorale s'est justifié à
plusieurs reprises affirmé avoir résolu
tous ses problèmes commission électorale
qui a aussi annoncé que le la
participation devrait s'établir à
environ 60 % ce qui serait un bien un
record au kenya jamais aussi peu
d'électeurs ne se serait déplacée vers
les urnes
voilà qui pourrait sonner le glas de
l'opposition à la junte en guinée elle a
dissous le front national pour la
défense de la constitution
motif ils agiraient comme une milice
privée
le collectif était à l'avant poste de la
contestation contre l'ancien président
alpha condé et récemment contre les
militaires au pouvoir c'est lui qui
avait organisé les manifestations fin
juillet des rassemblements interdits ou
cinq personnes ont été tuées à conakry
la correspondance de malik diakité
les militaires au pouvoir accuse le
mouvement d'organiser des manifestations
armée sur la voie publique et d'agir
comme une milice privée toujours selon
les autorités guinéennes je cite le mode
opératoire structure par des actions
violentes au cours des manifestations
interdites ou non autoriser des attaques
contre des individus que ne partagent
pas leur idéologie et des actions
ciblées contre les forces de l'ordre des
pratiques qui ne mettent en péril
l'unité nationale et la paix publique
selon le ministre de l'administration le
dessus pas de tous animés par une
volonté de taire toutes les voix
discordantes mais plutôt je suis dans
l'obligation en tant que ministre de la
décentralisation
dans le strict respect et des pouvoirs
qui me sont conférés en termes de
maintien d'ordre et de
et de l'établissement leur public
lorsque n'importe quelle organisation
dont les activités menace à la paix et à
la stabilité public dû procéder à la
dissolution pure et simple cette
décision des militaires au pouvoir en
guinée inquiète les organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme
l'émancipation de la démocratie passe
par les distances des types de
mouvements sociaux qui aussi être qu'à
un quart des falaises mais aussi des
principes voyez désillusion en france
faire mon travail le ballet citoyenne
aubry qui n'entraîne travail y en a
marre sénégal fait le même travail donc
si on se met dans une logique de dire
que toutes les voix dissonantes il faut
le taire il faut il faut
systématiquement les bayonnais et je
pense que cela ne pourra pas en tout cas
nous permettre le commanditaire de
construire notre jeune démocratie la
menace de dissolution du fonds national
pour la défense de la constitution
intervient alors que le mouvement
appellent à de nouvelles manifestations
dans le pays le dit c'est au prochain
anthony blinken poursuit sa visite sur
le continent le secrétaire d'état
américain en république démocratique du
congo à l'agenda des discussions les
tensions avec le voisin rwandais kigali
est accusé par kinshasa de soutenir les
attaques menées par le m23 dans l'est de
la rdc l'onu affirmé la semaine dernière
détenir des preuves de ce soutien
correspondance de clément monroe
la visite d' anthony blinken était très
attendue par les congolais qui
espéraient de sa part une condamnation
du rwanda le rwanda je le rappelle qui
est accusé dans un rapport confidentiel
de l'onu dont des extraits ont fuité la
semaine dernière de soutenir les
rebelles du m23 dans l'est de la rdc le
secrétaire d'état américain n'a
finalement pas à condamner explicitement
kigali mais il a affirmé que les états
unis était je cite préoccupé par les
conclusions de ce rapport et il a appelé
les différentes parties à respecter
l'intégrité territoriale de la rdc et à
cesser de soutenir le m23 ainsi que tout
autre groupe armé dans la région selon
anthony blinken la priorité est
désormais de mettre un terme à ces
violences et pour ce faire les états
unis entendent appuyer les efforts de
médiation à régionale menée par le kenya
et l'angola les questions sécuritaires
n'ont pas été les seuls évoqué autres au
cours de cette visite l'économie et les
investissements américains dans le pays
ont aussi été abordés anthony blinken a
également salué les efforts du
gouvernement congolais en matière de
démocratie et de lutte contre la
corruption enfin il a rappelé le rôle
crucial du pays dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
répondant à une question sur la récente
mise aux enchères par la rdc de 30 blocs
pétroliers et gaziers il a appelé le
gouvernement congolais à respecter ses
engagements en matière de protection
environnementale
et anthony à d'une canne qui se rendra
mercredi au rwanda précisément en côte
d'ivoire le parti de laurent gbagbo sort
de son silence il s'est exprimé pour la
première fois depuis la grâce
présidentielle accordée par alassane
ouattara l'ancien président il était
sous le coup je vous le rappelle d'une
condamnation de 20 ans de prison son
clan réclame l'amnestie en ligne de mire
la présidentielle de 2000 25 des
réactions recueillies par ange domaniaux
nous avons déclaré que nous ne sont pas
d'accord avec la grâce à ses pleines
établi mais
nous sommes en processus politique et
pour moi ce processus pour nous devons
aussi d'aller jusqu'au bout il va
arriver jusqu'à attaquer nous
l'attendions de l'armée si c'est contre
ça nous allons avancer et ça je peux le
porter mais pour que les nombreux
membres en leur temps de me laisser
filer le feu il a lui même dans la bulle
de quoi tu vois
une double explosion a frappé le nord du
burkina faso deux bombes sur la route
entre bourzanga et djibo quinze
militaires sont morts à des groupes
jihadistes sont soupçonnés d'être à
l'origine de cette attaque
une autre attaque celle de tessit mené
dimanche dans le nord du mali cette fois
le bilan ne cesse de s'alourdir à 17
soldats et quatre civils ont été tués
l'armée évoque également 22 blessés dans
ses rangs un camp militaire a été pris
pour cibles dans la région des trois
frontières une zone stratégique où
différents groupes djihadistes actifs ce
sont eux qui sont suspectés d'avoir mené
cette opération
à blanchir sa peau sur le continent le
phénomène n'a rien de nouveau et il
séduit de plus en plus malgré les effets
néfastes sur la santé au cameroun les
adeptes du blanchiment cutanée trouve
désormais leur bonheur dans une boisson
à l'origine une députée reportage 34 de
tony manga et michel boudreault
c'est curieux breuvage commercialisé
depuis plusieurs semaines par celle qui
est à l'origine de sa conception en
jetant du collagène à signer juste
superbe pour la peau d'une boisson
censée éclaircir à la peau vanté par
cette femme d'affaires qui est aussi une
députée controversée de l'opposition à
34 ans norman foster qui dirige une
entreprise de cosmétiques est au coeur
d'une vive polémique depuis qu'elle a
lancé ces boissons qui promet aux femmes
une peau plus blanche plus belle et plus
jeunes un contient peu près cinq
produits donc vous avez le collagène
vous l'alf arbitres in vous avez
l'obligation vous avez la boisson
minceur en usine sont totalement
certifié ils sont bio toute sécurité
vous buvez vous n'avez pas de souci de
l'art butine ou encore du glutathion des
substances qu'on retrouve dans la
plupart des produits utilisés pour la
dépigmentation de la peau mais ils sont
en vente libre sans ordonnance ni
contrôle médical est compris dans des
pharmacies comme celle ci
ces voix sont supposés contenir du
collagène sont très demandés par une
clientèle féminine qui veut s'éclaircir
la peau malgré les risques encourus et
puis ma fausse arme après la 6ème
s'apprécie de l'intérêt
n'était pas boire des produits
éclaircissants un risque majeur pour la
santé d'après les spécialistes depuis
des années le docteur henriette mélo se
bat contre ses produits de
dépigmentation pour cette der matt
holloway réputé avaler des molécules
comme l'alpha art butine peut avoir de
graves conséquences pour l'organisme al
fahm un but in est un proche qui nous
donc c'est un produit qui est utilisé
pour dépigmenter la peau et quand on
boit déjà
ça peut avoir d'autres effets
secondaires pas seulement au niveau de
la pop et au niveau
d autres organismes parce que la
dépigmentation n'a pas d'effets
seulement uniquement au niveau de la
peau ça peut entraîner d'autres maladies
et à l'hypertension et le diabète et le
cancer de la peau dans sa boutique la
députée femme d'affaires neurones foster
affirme que la consommation de ces
boissons dites éclaircissante est bien
autorisé au cameroun et malgré la
polémique le ministère camerounais de la
santé n'a jusqu'ici pas eu de réaction
officielle
culture intensive utilisation de
pesticides les menaces planent sur le
manioc aliments phare de l'ouest du
continent au nigeria des scientifiques
mise tout sur les ogm avec l'espoir
qu'une variétés plus résistantes
prennent racine laurent bht fia
dans ce marché dit bad and honour de les
gosses le manioc souvent s'achète et
s'échange tout au long de la journée
ici le commerce de ce tubercule poilus
va bon train mais depuis quelques années
les prix ne cessent d'augmenter
avant le sol était fertile la terre
était propice à la culture qu'on les
fermiers plantaient leurs manioc il géré
mais rapidement mais aujourd'hui la
qualité du sol s'est dégradée le
pesticide qu'on utilise pour combattre
les bactéries affecte les romans
symbole de prospérité
le manioc est un aliment phare en
afrique de l'ouest où les plantations
s'étendent de la guinée au cameroun mais
sa culture intensive a provoqué une
dégradation des sols qui chaque saison
perdante en fertilité et en minéraux
pour pallier ce problème
cette généticienne étudie de près l'adn
du tubercule afin de créer une nouvelle
variété de manioc plus résistante et
plus faciles à cultiver
nous essayons d'identifier ces jeunes et
de les transférer pour améliorer la
qualité de la culture ainsi que son
rendement
le but est de garantir la sécurité
alimentaire au nigeria mais aussi dans
le reste de l'afrique de
la culture du manioc dont 90% et produit
en afrique de l'ouest pourrait permettre
à la région de combattre la malnutrition
face à l'augmentation globale des prix
des denrées
si vous nous regardez depuis marrakech
le caire khartoum ont encore kinshasa
cela devrait vous rafraîchir je vous
emmène skier au lesotho à plus de 3000
mètres d'altitude un tout petit domaine
skiable le seul d'afrique australe
actuellement l'activité rien d'anormal 1
ce n'est pas lié aux changements
climatiques là bas c'est l'hiver
particularité du pays le seul au monde
dont tout le territoire est à flux de
1000 mètres au niveau de la mer
on se quitte sur ce vent frais c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui merci de votre
fidélité au journal de l'afrique
retrouver une aussi sur france 24 points
comme et nos réseaux sociaux prenez soin
de vous à demain
[Musique]